in the foyer assembling holy Square on
the green and officers will assist you
and advise you when it's deemed to safe
to return to the chamber
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
please note that this meeting has been
live streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
subsequently broadcast on the internet
does anyone intend to film the meeting
and that's a no so we move on
[Applause]
foreign
are any members wishing to speak under
20.1 this evening
and that's a no as well
I don't have any requests for public
speaking there's no members of the
public here so we move on to the main
agenda so apologies for absence I've got
councilor Leeds who's sub by councilor
town in
um councilor ratigan councilor Piper
Stuart Piper and councilor Moore who's
subbed by councilor Yates
are there any Declarations of Interest
councilor Boyd
hi chair um I would like to declare that
um I have a annual resident parking
permit which will come under fees and
charges so that's my Declaration of
interest thank you Council boy that's
noted
uh oh
thank you counselor
uh minutes of the previous meeting
we need to approve the minutes of the
yeah I believe as well I can't believe
on that section yes
okay the minutes of the previous meeting
on held on October 24 22 uh copy uh has
been circulated can I have a proposal
please
by councilor Moore and a second up and
seconded by Council Tomlinson door
members agreeing
thank you uh moving on to item four
we're gonna have a Cabinet member
presentation on the efficacy I've just
been practicing that word in my head of
using cag's approach in policy
development and decision making so I'm
going to call on upon our leader to make
that presentation
thank you chair and thank you for the
invitation
um OSP committee um it's not a visual
presentation it's a verbal presentation
so I thought that would be far more
interesting than looking a lot of
pictures
so as you're probably aware we currently
have four cabinet advisory groups
commonly known as cags
which are the climate change housing
local plan and local development scheme
fees and charges
these kags are made up of small group of
cross-party councilors commissioned by
myself as the leader to look at
particular issues of concern or interest
in those areas
they are most often and in this case
um for thanet District Council during
this Administration chaired by the
cabinet members that are responsible for
the areas of that work
that that is being looked at
so for instance the local plan I chair
because that comes under my portfolio
the climate change is chaired by
councilor Bob bayford that's his area of
um concern under this portfolio housing
for councilor Jill bayford fees and
charges as is most topical for this
evening by councilor David Saunders
the role of the KAG is to revise the
cabinet on issues under the remit of The
Keg so current on current matters of
climate change housing local plan fees
and charges
the KAG will often meet in private and
this has in some quarters drawn some
criticism and accusations of lack of
transparency
but I think it's important to clarify
the reason that the kegs need to be in a
safe place for the Frank exchange of
ideas without the fear of those people
watching or getting the wrong end of the
stick or selectively taking ideas out of
context
if all kags were in public then there
certainly would be times when ideas were
not discussed as they could be presented
as facts rather than purely ideas it is
an ideas and fact-sharing group of
people's group of counselors
further to that point is not the case
the kag's making decisions on policy
behind closed doors
and away from scrutiny by other councils
and the public it is not the role of the
CAG to make a decision and I emphasize
that they aren't decision-making it is
not a decision-making body a CAG does
not make decisions and there are no
votes
um is purely as I say a way of sharing
information cross-party inwardly and
outwardly on the subject uh the defined
subjects of the three items that four
items that are referred to
um in fact using the previous example of
the Net Zero strategy the strategy was
developed by officers using the climate
change CAG as a sounding board and then
the final draft strategy was brought to
this scrutiny panel for review before
eventually going to cabinet for approval
other commonly misheld perception is
that kags are also are being used as an
alternative to scrutiny reviews
I can see why some members might or
people might actually have come to that
conclusion but I do not believe this is
the case
a scrutiny review is a specific piece of
work that is time limited and takes a
specific question to which the review
would find the answer to
for example the panel last year did a
review on Coastal waste and is currently
undertaking a review covering the
relationship between town and Parish
councils in the district
the work of the KAG is entirely
different in that a KAG has an ongoing
role in advising cabinet on ongoing
issues this type of work would not be
appropriate for a scrutiny review and it
would not score well on the panel
scrutiny review criteria
so far cags have contributed to a wide
range of policies strategies and other
works these include Net Zero strategy
the revised local plan the housing
estate strategy the carbon reduction
plan and the housing assisted scheme
amongst others
that represents a very significant body
of work that kegs have worked on and do
I think that there's been successful and
worthwhile use of both officers and
members times yes I do
so whilst the work can be seen as
similar to kags and scrutiny
they do not perform they do perform
sorry very different roles
so that hopefully explains
my interpretation and the interpretation
of the difference the distinct
difference between the CAG function and
obviously the very important function of
overview and scrutiny
so thank you chair and um I obviously
open to any questions the panel might
have for me
yeah thank you leader so do members have
any questions uh to ask or comments to
make to our leader
oh hands up
cancer Huxley
thanks Jay thanks leader I'm just a
comment really
I'm on the housing and climate change
cags and I found them really really
positive really really positive I don't
think we should change it
um I think it's
really you know we had some really good
outcomes for me it's helped with my
casework because I've got good detailed
knowledge of what's going on
um we've had an honest discussion with
the officers and with other members of
the two kegs that I'm on and it's been
really positive and useful and so I
think we should keep it as it is thanks
guys counseling I'd Echo the words that
of council Huxley I just add that
they've been really useful I'm on the
housing one so they've been really good
at sharing ideas and concerns that we
have in our wards that maybe we can put
more emphasis on and I would not want to
see them change but the only addition I
would have is perhaps allowing some of
our independent councilors the chance to
be on to be on the board I know uh
councilor
Ruth Bailey was really disappointed to
not be on on the housing tag once the uh
the the leadership of the council
changed and I think we lost a lot by not
having her on there so that's the only
issue I'd have is can we give our
independent counselors the same chance
to be on these tags given they're not
decision making
yeah thanks counseling any more
questions comments
yes sir
nipped in there ahead of her cancer
Carrie Boyd um it's when I'm from an
officer's perspective I think given the
system of governance that we got in
place at the council with a cabinet
model and that we've got quite a large
number of counselors for the for the
size of the council we've got the kags
provide a real opportunity for those
that are outside either cabin or Shadow
cabinet to have an input into decision
making if we were in a under a different
model of governance say under a
committee model then you can make an
argument that the CAG well you wouldn't
have a cabinet but you wouldn't need
that sort of governance structure in
place so I think given not the given the
size of the number of councils we've got
and the governance model that we've got
with a cabinet and a strong leader
system means that we we really benefit
in terms of getting that cross-party
input into our decision making from
having those cabinet advisory groups set
up
I think it was cancer but
thank you chair
um I currently sit on two cabinet
advisory groups and absolutely love for
them so it gives me a really good
opportunity to get involved
um and a couple years ago I was on the
health and well-being one and I know
this came up in a meeting possibly six
to 12 months ago about it possibly
coming back
um so I just wondered where the health
and well-being or
um something around Community safety
we've got four cabinet advisory groups
which sit in the cabinet members book
Community safety or young people or
something around that isn't necessarily
accounted for in the cabinet advisory
groups so I just wondered whether there
was an option for that moving forward in
the new term
did you want to did you want to come
back yeah I mean I need to look back and
to discover why that was um dropped from
the actual CAG I think it was um
because we already have four
um now obviously we have to be
um
there has to be an officer present at
the kags as well so it might be to do
with resource
but I'll have to check back through the
records on that I'll have to refer to to
Nick and we'll have to look back through
there but um
obviously
counselors attending um is up to us to
make up the proportionality and the
difficulty is there and answering some
degree
um
counselor Wings question or Council
Austin can't remember which way around
it was now um regarding the independence
the problem there is when you have
proportionality then it's you know you
pick from your from your group the
trouble is when we have independent
Independence
um who goes on where and and who's it
fair to just select one
independent member as opposed to another
is it would be a difficult call into
asking who to go and walk I mean
presumably if if each independent
Council if we have four groups and we
have four independent independent
counselors then are they all willing to
sit on each one then that would that
would come across as fair but it's just
a difficult call when they are pure
Independence and uh um
to say well you can come on this one and
but you can't come on that one I'm just
wondering about the logistics if it were
but I mean certainly something that can
be looked at and I'll and I'll come back
to you councilor uh Boyd on the health
and wellbeing to be honest I can't
remember it would have been
it is the gift of the leader basically
and it's uh I think when I first took
control of the council um I looked
through it and I had to obviously decide
the areas that were generating the
majority of the work and the background
and there's a hell of a lot of
background that goes on especially on
you know the local plan itself because
the legislation is moving as we know and
the local plan moves from different
stages so
um and with the climate change you know
that's moving all the time there's a
heavy workload on the on the housing and
obviously fees and charges is
particularly prevalent this this time of
the year so you know the workloads do
vary but I'll certainly have a look at
that but it might be to do with office
and resource or it might been that I had
to basically fit it into the calendar
Etc but I'll come back to you on that as
soon as I find out
thank you Council Austin
thank you chair I just wanted to pick up
really on what Chris was saying about
about constitutional models and I
wondered leader whether I know at the
very beginning of this Council there was
some discussion about whether we should
explore whether the council should
explore a committee system and talk to
other councils that were adopting that
do you feel that this model using the
kags and but still having the the
cabinet system is getting them the
council the best benefit out of the
combined expertise and ideas of
counselors
absolutely
um
I've studied other councils that have
committee systems I have a good
relationship with the leader of Kent
Canterbury city council who have just
gone back to a cabinet system
the problem is with committees
um and and it seems to be
um
pretty standard across for all
committee-led councils is that
it gives an opportunity for things to to
move around a lot but not decisions
being made at least with a strong
cabinet you know you move things forward
and as I can witness or you've witnessed
and being leader of this Council
if we'd been under a committee system I
can assure you we wouldn't have moved
this Council on like we have in the last
18 months 20 months because what we've
actually done in this Council over the
last of that 20 months to sort out the
issues that we had here
they certainly wouldn't have been under
under a committee system I know
committee systems are favored by groups
that don't necessarily hold majority of
council and I can understand that but if
you want um a fast-moving
decision-making good process then you
don't want to give any anywhere for
either members or officers to actually
hide and and I think and and forgive me
officers if I'm talking our turn here
but um you know a committee system I
think is probably easier for the
officers to work with if they don't want
to move things forward in such a
progressive manner I think the way we've
got this model set up here is absolutely
ideal and I think we've really
demonstrated with our officers that
we've come through quite a lot of
adversity because we have this system so
I think the kags are absolutely
essential to support a cabinet strong
cabinet structure system
and I mean obviously turkeys don't vote
for Christmas so um that even if I
wasn't the leader of this Council I
would still endorse working within a
council that has a cabinet because I can
see the both sides of the coin and it is
certainly more effective
thank you Council King
okay
thank you leader I mean I actually
wanted to
um you know support what councilor Boyd
said because I think it's something
really important and something that
we're missing challenging in this
Council that we already know many parts
of planet have significant health
problems and although it's not a direct
Council role there's lots we can do that
would improve Community Health and the
same with Community safety which also
impacts on health so personally I would
just like to see that happen so thank
you for your suggestion councilor Boyd
[ __ ] just uh I mean I have absolutely
no problem of forming it obviously it
would only be formed for a very short
period and I'm not sure the
effectiveness of it I mean it would be
formed in February and February March
um and April and then again it's down it
is the gift of the leader
um to decide so I could we could form it
and have it sitting for
um a couple of three months so that at
least they could get maybe terms of
reference together and
um then it's up to whoever that may be
in in May to whether they want to carry
on and indeed the other kegs as well so
um with Nick if Nick's gonna nod at me
whether we could just um get that
together maybe just a small committee
um a small CAG
um a small keg as opposed to
medium-sized midi cab oh that's it
so that sounds sounds like penny so um
Nick I don't know would it be something
we could do for three months and then
try and set a president going forward or
how do you feel about that there's
there's no reason why you couldn't but
I'd look at Chris with a big star that
said resource that would be my only my
only reservation on that front other but
yeah from a purely constitutional review
point of view then yeah we could do that
but just caveat that with a healthy dose
of we need some resource to do that
okay well
um if we can take that away and have a
discussion
um maybe um you know I don't mind
putting some time towards the terms of
reference and we don't
necessarily need an officer to to attend
at the meeting but certainly you'd need
an officer just to help with the terms
of reference so and just fitting it into
the Constitution I think it has to go
into the Constitution and it obviously
has to be added into websites Etc so um
well we'll explore it anyway if it's not
a massive amount of work um we could we
could um set the concept in in motion
anyway okay
any more comments or questions for the
leader
okay that's a note so I'd like to thank
the leader for coming to the meeting and
giving her presentation thanks so much
my pleasure I don't my
my open fire and my um slippers warm
slippers behind thank you chair yeah
thank you
like moving on on the agenda to item
number five which is fees and charges
for 2023 uh to 2024. so I'll call on
quick splendale to introduce the report
thank you chair so this report went to
cabinets last week on Thursday sets out
the proposed fees and charges for the
forthcoming Financial year
um they're set out in detail within the
annex the report that sets out both the
um cash increase and the percentage
increase we've aimed for a broad 10
increase in fees and charges
across all the services that we charge
for wherever possible wherever
practically possible to do so largely
linked to the high inflation environment
that we're operating in in order to
recover
um the costs where it's uh where that's
the purpose of the charge obviously some
fees and charges are not set just for
cost recovery there can be other
purposes for them be that to influence
residents or customer Behavior to limit
or ration the availability of a
particular service so I don't intend to
go through the fees and charges Annex in
detail because obviously there's a lot
in there to digest
in terms of coming back from some of the
questions that were raised at cabinet on
Thursday I think the main point of
Interest was around fees and charges for
car parking we have looked to try and
produce some additional information
unfortunately we've not been able to get
it all out of the system we have had
some system issues with um
over the last day or so but what I can
sort of tell members in terms of the
position on car parking I believe it was
Council Everett that raised the points
around
the fact that the majority of car
parking income in terms of the
presentation and the annex it looked
like it was just an increase in the
budget for the Mill Lane Car Park what
I've been provided with for or by my
team is a breakdown of the income that's
been achieved from
Elaine Royal Harbor and then the other
heading is just the grouping of all
other car Parks under a general heading
the budget set out for the fourth for
The Current financial year are there's a
hundred thousand pound for Mill Lane 178
000 for Royal Harbor and then it's 1.367
million for all the others put together
if um if I just start with Mill Lane the
hundred thousand pound budget in terms
of the amount of income
um either estimated for The Current
financial year because we've not
finished yet or what we've actually
received in the last couple of financial
years so looking at uh Mill Lane we're
actually forecasting to receive income
closer to 300 000 there that's the
figure that we received in 2122 that was
299 971 pounds to be precise and 25
Pence so you see there's quite a lot of
room over above the budget there even
going back to 2021 we were in the
pandemic we still got 75 000 pounds
worth of income I think a lot of that
was actually in relation to staff
permits that are recharged and the cost
of those allocated to
um the income that's earned from the car
park
um a bit of wooden dollar accounting
recharging there but it still represents
the value of the spaces that are being
used so the reason why it's been shown
at the 95 increases pretty much to
realign the budget that we've got there
in mole Lane because we've only got a 95
000 pound budget but we're significantly
over achieving on that
if you look at the Royal Harbor budget
well you can't look at it sorry if I can
explain or half a budget to you my
apologies 178
000 uh
in terms of the income that's been
received it was 214 000 last year and
we're expecting it to be 190
000 for The Current financial year so
that's closer so there's not necessarily
A need to alter that budget the reason
that we're not altering the budgets
across the other car parts is because
those are the ones that are down at the
moment so it talks about a 1.3 million
well 1.4 or most rounding up million
budget there so it's one uh 1367
000 pound budget that's the combination
of all the other uh General Car parks
um we got in just under a million pound
last year so we're almost a quarter of a
million down on those car parks and the
other uh car Parks this year we're
looking at being uh forecast
1.029 to 1 million and twenty nine
thousand pounds
so we're still considerably down there
on the budget so that's really trying to
explain the presentation of the figures
I think there was a question as to why
are we only increasing the budget at
Mill Lane it's just because the the way
those budgets are profiled if I can put
my hand in the air I think the budgets
have just been profiled incorrectly in
the past and this is just realigning
them to get to a more accurate
representation of the budgets for the
forthcoming Financial year
in terms of the overall increase in
parking charges we have presented a 10
increase appreciate this is not an easy
decision
um to approve given that many of uh
residents and our customers because
there's lots of people who use the car
parts aren't just residents we have a
number of visitors to the district
particularly in the summer months whose
car Parks will be feeling the effects of
the cost of living crisis uh there's a
lot of regulation in place around car
parking charges we've been picked up on
it by the Auditors in the past in terms
of when we tried to introduce new car
parking schemes you can't do that just
to generate income if we were to
introduce the charge that say we want to
do this thermometer money we'd be in big
trouble equally we can't increase car
parking charges to close a gap in the
budget because that's not allowed the
reason and you set an amend car parking
charges is
to manage traffic flow that's got to be
the primary purpose of it so the reason
we look to increase fees charges for car
parking this year is because we are in a
high inflation environment and we wanted
to ensure the impact of those car
parking charges weren't diluted because
effectively as inflation goes up if you
don't increase your charges they're
becoming cheaper in real terms
um
so that's the principle that's the sort
of rationale behind the increase
I did explain that the 10 increase
doesn't does produce an additional
income as we would expect all other
things being equal assuming that demand
doesn't decrease
the way we view that from an accounting
perspective given the regulatory
framework is that's a very welcome
byproduct
um if there was that's probably the best
way I can frame it particularly if I was
trying to explain our strategy and
position with the Auditors because they
would be looking at this so we welcome
the fact that it would generate
additional income first but that's not
the primary concern when we're setting
them the primary concern is around what
we think fees and charges will do in
terms of managing traffic flow
that was the main sort of
um uh point that was raised so I just
wanted to set that out at the outset but
I'm happy to take any further questions
on car parking or any other items that
are listed in the fees and charges
reports
oh thank you Chris before I open it to
everybody uh Council boarding Council
wing of X declared an interest so no if
you want to make your comments first
and then you can leave so
before that for the open discussion yeah
foreign yeah so um just to make clear so
two members have declared an interest
normally they would leave for the
discussion at the item and the vote
um but because OBS P has public speaking
rights
um there is the and it's explained in
the Declaration of Interest advice and
the agenda that both members are allowed
to speak and and contribute to at the
start of this item to make your points
as long as you don't cover the bits that
you're declaring an interest in
obviously and then after you've made
your points that's when you you'd leave
at the end and then come back afterwards
okay Nick so sorry if I just because
obviously fees and charges is a very
wide rumor and we're not just talking
about car parking is it possible to
segment the item so that we could
discuss car parking and then allow the
councils the opportunity to come back in
if they wanted to contribute to any of
the other items in the report
sorry yeah I was careful but I thought
it might be worth passing I don't think
we can okay thanks I'm sorry that's why
but you can make all your points at the
beginning of the the discussion
um so you're not and then you have to
leave yeah yeah
so Council board first I I will say
something because I spent hours reading
this last night so
actually I was like oh just dizzy um I
really don't have too much to say apart
from there was something that looked odd
um and I don't know if it's a typo three
times
um that I just want to make sure is
correct so uh Joss Bay over five hours
is an increase of
990.91 which is a lot more than 10
percent
um and if you're going to charge someone
54 pounds to stay there five hours they
might have something to say about that
um so that is just by uh broadstairs and
there's also the same mistake if it is a
mistake who knows
um it's Mildred's Bay in Westgate again
the same uh it's I think it's just a
typo where it's meant to be six pounds
but they put 60 so it looks like it's
gone up by 990 percent
um and that's on page 30.
of this of the report um so if you can
have a look at that because I don't know
if that adds anything to your overall
calculations and then another one which
was allotments water on page 47
um water charge per 25 square meters is
up
273.83 which seems quite a lot but again
I'm not an expert on water or allotments
or car Parks um but I thought I'd raise
them just in case because they just
looked a bit weird that was all
uh Nick is now the right time for me to
answer that as that permitted thank you
um thank you for your eagle-eyed and uh
observations and the uh obviously the
hours you've spent um looking as I I
concur I obviously would need to confirm
but I'm
panicking confirm that is obviously
um I think someone's just hit the wrong
button when they've entered it into the
spreadsheet it doesn't have any impact
on the budgets because we've obviously
looked at income for car Parks overall
but we obviously need to correct that
because we don't want to prove that fees
and charge and then have to come back to
you
um to get it revised downwards so thank
you for your contribution
allotments I need to look at that I'm
not sure sorry
thank you councilman councilor win thank
you I did I just said it and it was to
do with the multi-story car park the
Royal Harbor car park in uh it's got
nothing to do with me because I don't
particularly use that but uh I'm really
well I welcome the fact that we're going
to eventually buy it because that's
clearly in there and what I was asking
in addition is it's three million I
think he's the the purchase price is
that true in there but is it does that
include does that include uh
refurbishment because we know we still
haven't got a lift and it's a pretty
Tatty car park
um so that's set out in the following
item in the budget report so
um I'm sorry to cover it off at that
point in time just to
um that's cleaner at that point I'm
happy with that Nick yeah
I think says I'd wear with a hand sorry
comments and questions members
it's just Council Yates
thank you Jeff
um so the labor group is unhappy with
the 10 parking proposals and its impact
on local residents
we do have a recognize the need for
Budget adjustments if we are to make
changes as the the cabinet budget was
only last Thursday we do need a bit more
time to consider the options
and that's options as a group before you
make any proposals
um so at this time
uh we're not making any proposals to
this thank you I think you can see Yates
Council King
thank you
um this is not about car parking I'd
just like to comment on the bulky waste
and green garden waste charges now I
don't disagree with them but I'm just
interested to make sure that they
actually work as it's intended like it
says it's expected that the bulky waste
charges will actually help to reduce fly
tipping which is a particular problem in
some parts of our area and
um will this be monitored to make sure
that it does actually do that I'm not
sure how good our monitoring is of fly
tipping occurrences anyway
um because I was looking at the charges
and then I was thinking one of the
problems we often have is when a flat is
come to the end of the lease tenants
have moved out or left or what have you
and then the entire flat is just dumped
somewhere and that's a lot of items and
that actually might have been cheaper I
mean I know often it is just um but it
might have been cheaper under the five
items collection than five individual
items now so I would hate to see
something come in that actually put
people off from using it so I would put
in a request for that to be monitored
for its impact equally with the green
garden waste which I think is an
excellent scheme
um and I think it's quite fair enough
for the cost to go up but we want to
encourage people to you know use the
green garden waste system so again it
would be interesting to see the figures
about whether some people then opted out
of it particularly as I know some
residents had problems with the green
waste collection this year so they might
choose that they're not going to invest
in it this year anyway so it's just
about monitoring thank you thank you I
can't say Okay Council Austin
thank you Chad
um I wanted to pick up on car parking
just from the point of view that
obviously as a green group we don't want
to encourage people to use private cars
whether other Alternatives available our
difficulty is that we would have to have
a decent public transport system and uh
walking and cycling friendly towns and
we're struggling a bit with that in
terms of the relationship that we have
with KCC and the difficulty of actually
getting them to listen to local
information about about what's needed so
we can sympathize with the labor group's
concerns there what I want to know
really from Chris was
um do we think that putting charges up
by the similar rate to inflation will
actually have any effect on uh customer
demand or not and then picking up on
councilor King's question I also have a
question for Penny if she doesn't mind
which is about bulky waste we had safer
streets projects which was supposed to
have some some kind of free bulky waste
collection as part of them has that
happened have we got any information on
that do we know anything about about
that it just seemed like a really good
idea from the point of view that we
could monitor the impact of that on on
fly tipping in the area but I don't know
whether we've actually got any
Intelligence on that
if I just come in quickly on that one I
don't know the answer I didn't prepare
for that question on this meeting so I
came with my parking hat on not my
community safety sorry could I email you
about it thank you I will find out in
terms of the green waste so we were very
mindful of the charges there it's an
important service
however it is a service area that's seen
a significant increase in costs over the
last 12 18 months with fuel prices going
up obviously they're starting to come
back down but when we were initially
looking at this there were record highs
so it's a it is a service that we expect
sorry without going into two technical
terms we don't think the price is very
elastic so in other words we don't think
there'll be a big drop in demand for
prices going up I think residents and
customers value the service I think
provides good value for money and if you
compare it to the cost of either driving
to a household waste recycling center or
disposing otherwise so even with the
increase in price we still think it
represents volume for money but cabinet
we're mindful of of how far those prices
could be pushed and we had come
conversations around that and we settled
it I think at a a position that
reflects that we are still recovering
the costs associated with the service
but it will be a service that's still
valued by the by our customers
and on the car parking Chris so what was
the exact weather do you expect there
will be any impact on Demand by raising
I mean the position at the moment and
carping is what car parking is that it
would maintain it in terms of current
levels because
um we're we're prices are largely
staying the same in real terms obviously
we appreciate everyone else's
personal and can maybe squeezed because
of the cost of living crisis but putting
that to one side if you think about the
impact of prices to some real terms it
it should maintain it in terms of
actually affecting positively or
negatively I think that falls to the
outcome of the car parking strategy when
we'll really be looking at which car
Parks do we want to be directing people
to use in terms of managing traffic flow
and and other other sort of more stress
strategic decisions around the use of
car Parks I'm going to take your points
around
ensuring we've got joined up sort of
public transport and
friendly policy around walking and
cycling I think
um that really Nets in nice with the
local plan policy and the work that I
think we've already touched on in terms
of the local plan CAG all those things
need to be you know be joined at the hip
in terms of your parking policy and your
local plan policy
thank you anyone else got any comments
or questions on fees and charges
Okay so we've asked uh if we want to
make any recommendations to take forward
to Cabinet are there any any recommend I
know you had some things about that as
regards to fees and charges are there
any recommendations
no
okie dokie so well
just go and get
there we'll bring the others back in
okay so welcome back councilor Boyd
counseling so moving on to item number
six on the agenda budget 23 24 and 2023
to 27 medium-term financial plan so I'm
going to call on Mr Chris Blundell again
to introduce the report thank you chair
I think most of probably heard me talk
to some length about this budget already
so I try and keep it short I think this
is a really positive budget certainly
the most positive budget I've been
involved with for a long time in local
government were putting more money into
the budget uh considerably more money
into the budget both due to inflation
pressures but actually investment and
services as well there's no significant
Savings in terms of impact on Staffing
but we've still found ways to make
better use of our money through treasury
management activities or otherwise
I'm happy to take any questions I don't
propose to go through and and any
further detail on that because I think
you've all heard it from me already
yeah thank you Chris uh so over to
members do you have any questions or
comments you wish to make
okay Council sorry I've got a few and
then a big one uh let me get my I I I
really do welcome it we've got a huge
amount of money that is that I hope is
going to make maximize benefits for the
area so I think it's really positive
that we've got the huge amount of money
I think it's is it 50 000 Chris uh but
obviously sorry the capital program yeah
55 million over four years five million
yeah so it's a huge amount of money so I
think we're all really pleased that that
amount of money has come into the
authority and congratulations should be
given to the the officers that actually
completed all the extensive paperwork to
ensure that we got the funding coming in
and obviously to the people that put
this budget together it's one of two
things that I just want to ask questions
for I'm really I'm really pleased that
there's 800k for repairs of Maintenance
under 4.13 do we and I'll ask them one
at a time do we have priorities for this
funding I.E which asset have we already
got Assets in mind that we need to spend
this money on or is it a case of where
wait and see what happens
in terms of prioritization so we've
commissioned the number of surveys of
our property some of our I think there's
a hit list of our 20 sort of key assets
and then alongside that a survey for all
of our toilets so once we've got the
result of those surveys we'll start
being able to prioritize those projects
will also look where possible
to capitalize further expenditures so it
may result in coming back to members for
further approval and we'll be looking to
do creative things and potentially
disposing of some assets to invest in
others so it's all linked to The Wider
investment in the property team so it's
not just the 800 000 in terms of repairs
and maintenance but it's a big increase
in the Staffing side of the property
team to allow us to drive rent renewals
and lease renewals that should bring in
more income to the council dispose those
assets that are
are Surplus to our requirements and get
us our corporate asset management plan
back up to date and drive forward what
we want to do with all our assets so
that's sorry that I've gone through that
around the houses there and rambled on
but the the short answer is no not at
the moment we don't have a priority list
but we will have it soon you've got a
plan which is good the next one is uh
I'm really pleased that we've got
Coastal enforcement at 40 at 4.14 five
new posts which is a great thing given
we've had a huge number of obviously
complaints about jet skis one of the
things but also about antisocial
behavior on beaches litter dropping etc
etc what I really want to know is uh
there'll be there'll be five new posts
what will their priorities be and how
will they be deployed around the coast
because obviously I think we've got 19
Bays some of them are obviously bigger
and more popular than others I don't
know the operational specifics
um and I may have she's come with a
parking hat on so and I don't even think
it's Penny's area I think it was sick
yeah it was certain of um Mike cumber
um so I think I'm afraid we'll have to
get back to again in terms of
prioritization I'm not sure how those
resources will be used the only thing I
can add is we are charging some of that
resource to the D Crim Reserve which is
the amount Reserve that we use for on
street car parking so we'll be flexible
in terms of the resource that is one of
Penny's area so in the offices in the
winter months when there's obviously
less Coastal activity there's fewer
people using the beaches we will
redirect some of those resources to
allow us to do further sort of town
center car parking enforcement and other
related enforcement activities but I'm
afraid I can't
um sort of give you any further detail
beyond that oh oh the leader may be able
to give some further details thank you
Ash
um obviously this comes under my um
portfolio
um and the discussion discussions really
is to be as flexible as we can with
these officers because if you have a
rigid
structure and beaches and etc etc that
they manage and it was thought to be
wanting them to be more mobile and more
fluid if you like on on and take some
intelligence of activities that are
going on especially when there are
events on because obviously
if there's an event on in one town then
you might need to pull some resources
over so it was thought that it would be
more of a as a team a flexible team that
would be
um
uh utilized according to to the pinch
points on on the areas um to cover the
events but to be more fluid so if you if
you start to be rigid about this this
enforcement officer is is for that beat
uh you know for that beach and this
beach then that becomes very rigid and
and that's probably not the way to
manage it so working on intelligence
information coming in from our events
team and from other instances that we've
experienced in the past we've known that
we've had problems uh on Margate Beach
where there were certain entities of
young people coming down on the train
and then they were getting off they they
were being stopped at Margate so then
they were getting off at birchington and
Westgate and walking through and it was
all sorts of so we need to gather the
intelligence which is which is being
done and then that team will be very
very fluid and versatile on what they're
operating on so don't really want to be
specific about it because actually
that's probably not the right way to run
that sort of team so that's a discussion
that has gone on at the coast then
foreshores portfolio meeting so um my
objective obviously was to get the
resource in there
um because that's what's been lacking as
you know so um that's hopefully helps um
explain a little bit about the thought
behind it but it will be managed as it
as it goes forward it sounds like a
sensible plan at 4.19 with CCTV so I'm
obviously pleased to see more CCTV and
especially as it links with the uh the
main concern of our residents I think
just over 50 was feeling safe in our
communities I just want to ask how does
our CCTV system CCTV system link in with
the police system because my
understanding is sometimes speaking
speaking to our peop our police offices
is they they can't access our system
which obviously affects Gathering
evidence for crime
I don't know the answer I don't know if
anyone else here okay yeah I thought you
might I didn't
know and they they also can come in to
view it so they if they have the right
um authorizations they can come in and
View and and also if there's been an
incident they can get request uh us to
review and download it and provide it if
there is evidence on it so yes they have
it I will back that one back to them
next time that crops up
uh
hang on
obviously the Margate tidal pool maybe I
should have declared an interest here
because I do swim off the Western
Undercliff it's not the Margate tidal
pool though uh and obviously I see
there's a 11k concession going into the
Margate tidal pool what does this mean
and how might it impact on the other
users particularly the large number of
sea swimmers and it's one of the few
safe spaces for sea swimmers to swim
that use the tidal pool all year round
my understanding is that Paul's not
supposed to be used for swimming the
Margate tidal pool is um it's one of the
re one of the reasons we're looking to
get a concession arrangement in there is
to allow us to provide lifeguard
services to stop One-Stop people
um the lifeguard should stop people
using but also the fact that we've got
an operational concession
um I'm expecting pad loads and and the
like that should the presence of them
alone I would have thought should stop
people swimming in it as well so that's
the the designated use of the tidal pool
there
yes absolutely
if you want me to add a fraction to that
um
so the tidal pool
um isn't covered by the rnli lifeguards
that look after the main Beach so it's
not
it is the tidal Port
um that is adjacent to the name behind
the nylon rock well you know the Elliott
toilets basically if you look straight
down there on the sun deck it's that
pool there which is not assuming it is
not a swimming it is a tidal pool but
designated by
um default from a boating pool because
it used to have pedalos Etc on it but
our main concern is
um although it hasn't had a concession
on it for a long while that paw is not
covered by the RNR lifeguards therefore
we have as a council we have a we have a
risk element here which we have to sort
we have to actually solve so the only
way we can solve it is to find the
revenue to actually have an own employee
lifeguard to look after that Paul
otherwise we'll have to close the pool
and the only way you can close the pool
is to actually open up the back end of
it so that it actually which will be I'd
hate to see that um to actually lose a
pool that is a historic value especially
as it got so much coverage in the Empire
of light I think that maybe the
concession could be found to actually
fund having its own independent
lifeguard on there so it would either be
fun enough funds to for us to provide
some sort of lifeguard cover or to find
a concession that could pay to actually
have have its own cover there and we
could stipulate
[Music]
um
the times and of cover for that pool but
it is imperative we cannot have that
pool without any attendance of a
lifeguard open this summer because we
are at risk so we have to find a
solution for that and the last thing I
want to do is put a bulldozer through
the back wall so that it actually is no
longer a pull but it is not a swimming
pool it is it is actually meant for
boating
so just to confirm because you know I'm
a native of Ramsgate it's not the
Walpole Bay tidal pool it's the one
person really not no um no that's still
swimming okay I've got the pictures to
prove that on uh on the on the um TV so
uh yeah
uh I want to mention the Ramsgate
leveling up fund it's probably my Big E
and again we've got 19.4 million which
is good with 14 million to be spent in
this year called into the here what I
also noticed in the document further
down is that we have a number of uh a
number of things going on on the port
and around the harbor which constitute a
further
1.045 million of borrowing to be spent
of which about 700 000 is this this
2023-24. uh one of one of the and it I
the next item I'm going to mention the
next item that the HRA item is is
absolutely brilliant because even down
to the a window being replaced in a
building a maintenance of the you know
refurbishment of the tower blocks it's
all there and it's all costed I don't
get the same feeling around the pool so
there's a lot of things going on in the
port and around the harbor
that I don't see properly costed I also
have concerns I mean there's 300K to be
borrowed to be spent on birth one I'd
just like to confirm was birth one the
birth that had the walkway that
collapsed in and killed six people in in
1994. what is that birth presently being
used and what do we intend to use that
birth for it was the walkway uh on on
that birth and the the report that came
out of that incident wasn't very
favorable in a in three for three main
areas including the US running the port
I'd just like to see a bit more detail
I'm very concerned about you know I'm
very concerned about our potential to
bring in a ferry but I I just want to
know that we've and it says earlier in
the documentation that groups have met
together and reviewed this and
prioritized it and we've looked at the
risk and we've looked at possible income
generation and clearly with housing we
build a few more houses and there is a
direct income coming in uh I just want
to see a bit more detail and you know I
do live in Ramsgate and even some of the
things I'm not quite clear what they are
so there's some development on the East
Pier which I am guessing it's
refurbishment of the the building that
contains the harbor Brasserie and the
yacht club uh race Hut uh personally as
as the World Council and also a member
of overview and scrutiny I'd like to
request that somebody walk me round or
walk us or the ward councilors around
the port so that you can and explain
what's being done to each building I I'd
also like to see the forward modeling so
we we we're going to obviously repair
birth one with the row row birth I'm not
quite sure how much the row row birth is
going to cost because there's not a
breakdown in that in that 15 million or
14 million whatever it was and then
obviously we've got births four or five
we repair two births we hopefully bring
a ferry in but have we costed the risk
to this authority of actually the
ongoing forward costs of additional
Staffing of additional maintenance and
additional repair I don't I'd like to
personally see that information even if
it's an estimate and a sort of a a best
case and worst case scenario going
forward
and I'm just not happy that there's
enough detail here for me for me to be
happy about the spend of this money
foreign
you're correct in terms of what's set
out in the report there is
um I think it's referred to as the
capital team or Capital Group which is a
group of officers that are primarily
um members of CMT but some other
specialist officers
um so Grant Burton for example our
capital projects manager
officers that work in ICT and housing we
all get together might come as a key
member of the group as well the director
responsible for the port and look
through the schemes in detail there is
behind each one of these a proposal a
project a capital project sort of
initiation form I'm happy to share the
details of that with with counselors
that are that would like to see them it
supports out the detail that justifies
these schemes each scheme needs to get
above 100 in order to make it onto the
capital program that sets out there's a
variety of different criteria it has to
be assessed against whether as health
and safety implications whether it's a
corporate priority whether it will
generate income and they score
appropriately according to that so
that's the sort of assessment process it
goes through again like I said just
repeat yourself happy to share that with
any members that wish to see that in
order to get the budget through in terms
of birth
um one mind standing is that's the birth
that Services the wind farms that are
there so I don't know the exact
um I don't know I don't know that layout
but from the proposals forms I've read
and they're just the general
familiarization I've got with the Skins
I think that's the wind farm one I'm not
sure of the history I'm afraid that
predates me
um but yeah happy to supply that
information I don't know if any if Ash
this is your portfolio of anything else
you'd like to add sorry I'm throwing you
under the bus there a bit
um well my understanding is one is is
the wind farm uh birth
so um obviously in order we actually
generate quite a lot of revenue from
um the wind farm so we need to look
after the bursts on that
um again endorse the capital program
expenditure there's a very high
um
well there's a there's a real strict
criteria for a point scoring criteria um
I think the hundred points is um
uh having looked at it and worked out
the criteria you've got to score score
on quite a whole wide variety of
of options and achievements to actually
get
permission to be granted this uh
expenditure so
um testing yes yes the stress test so um
I mean obviously the it you know the
ease of work in Port so there's lots of
stuff going on all the time
um but I'm I'm sure that we can provide
breakdowns of it I mean although I'm
portfolio holder and I meet regularly
with um
with um
Luke and with Mike Humber and the shadow
leader also comes along
um as was witnessed when we were
actually went on to birth four five onto
the actual um pontoon so I actually
wanted to believe that it actually was
there and installed because of the pain
that we've been through to get there
um so and uh the investment actually on
the bus from the leveling up fund is
actually 3.5 million I believe just
under 3.5 million
the testing obviously of uh the
Believers and the non-believers
regarding the port is well we'll have to
uh we'll have to wait and see but we
certainly won't it's not an election
pledge to say that we'll be doing this
we'll be doing that I mean there is a
great deal of work that will that will
need has gone on and needs to go on to
actually evidence whether or not this is
the right thing to do
um certainly as a leader I'm not one to
make decisions from the heart they
definitely make from the head and and I
take strict you know attention pay
strict attention to the officers and to
the experts in this field but um you
know
I always believed in the airport and I
am probably the same stance on the port
whereas I believe there is a port and as
the as the cabinet made
the statement earlier well actually it
wasn't earlier this year was it was late
last year that we believe that was the
path that we wanted to follow so um but
the proof will be in the pudding we will
listen to The Experts and uh go from
there but I'm sure Chris can release
information that is prevalent to the
backup that
the capital expenditure that is shown in
the budget could I just request a visit
to the port because the concern over
birth one was came from a number of
residents so clearly a number of
residents think birth one is the old
birth that collapsed the walkway that
collapsed if the ward councilors get a
better idea of exactly which birth is
which then we can back some of this
information back and it would be nice
there are some things there that I I
don't recognize the names of the
buildings and and we have you know it's
on our patch it's our world we've got a
genuine interest I hope the Sally I hope
we get a ferry I'll be the first one to
buy a ticket but that well I hope we get
a ferry I hope it's a Sally line that's
my that's my link that's my link to uh
that's my link to Ramsgate and than it
uh but it you know and it doesn't mean
I'm not here to support it I'm here to
the overview and scrutiny is about
asking questions and making sure money
is being appropriately spent and that's
what I I think we should do
um for my chef yeah um I'll speak with
um Mike Humber and uh we'll see what
what we can do on that um uh obviously
it's a very controlled area and it is a
working Port so you know it'd have to be
um
uh sensibly handled but um High Visa
hard hats and hard boots and I've got
all the gear all right anyway I'll have
a word with Mike and see um what he
feels about it and maybe right I
wouldn't recommend we do it actually
right this moment because it's blooming
freezing out there we're trying to pick
a nice day
are you
thank you counselor I think we all live
on in Hope for the port I think I think
the heady days of smorgasbord and those
cruises need to come back uh Council
Austin
I wanted obviously to pick up on on a
couple of things that counselor Wing
said
um particularly it's it's really welcome
to hear how the process has been Chris
and I wish we'd known that before we've
been asking for business plans around
the leveling up stuff for Ramsgate since
it first came in and we've seen nothing
nothing nothing nothing nothing nothing
so it's really good to know that that's
going to be available to us and we're
going to be able to see how uh how these
things have been scored how the planning
has has gone and it would have been nice
to have have had more information
earlier but it's great to have it now
um just a couple of things on the uh on
the port and and going from the the
major to the minor you heard me say at
um the KAG and you've heard me say since
why are we not using in the short term
the bits of land on the port that are
not at the moment earmarked for anything
for things like campervan storage
um a large storage containers Etc we
know we've got a waiting list for those
why are we not capitalizing on that now
even if it's only a six-month
Arrangement it it wouldn't be a massive
money spinner but it would be helpful it
seems to me silly that we're not
considering doing that when we've got
those areas uh we sat here with my
Columbus presentation with the lovely uh
plans with lilac circled areas I went
back to my slides to try to find it in
fact but I can't find a copy of it but
there are certainly big areas of the
port that the moment I understand we're
not doing anything with I know you said
there might be stuff coming through but
it's a question I think of when stuff's
coming through and again
about us knowing that with award
counselors we we should know it so
there's something else I want to say but
I know you want to come back on that
yeah in terms of that I know Mike cumber
the director that's um responsible for
services always actively looking at
opportunities but Mike's got a really
large sort of remit at the moment in
terms of the level of resources I think
this is sort of uh reflective of the the
number of sort of senior managers that
we've had available in the organization
for the last best part of the year
really
um but I'm hoping the long term will
become the short term pretty soon in
terms of the port and what we're looking
at and we'll be able to bring to
councilors sooner rather than later but
in terms of the immediacy I know
um we've looked at various different
things whether it be car storage with
the Jeffco shipments
um and various other sort of
opportunities as they are presented to
us but we're also very mindful of not
tying our hands because a lot of these
will have have that they'll want a
certain length of time but contractual
commitments and we don't want to sort of
um restrict what we can do in the long
term with the port so it is a bit of a
balancing act
thank you yes and I think that's why I
was suggesting things like container
storage and whatever because obviously
there's much more within our own uh
around control what you actually said
about Mike and being you know having so
many responsibilities actually leads on
to my other comment which is it's really
good to see this budget
um a not having any compulsory
redundancies but B that the investment
in Staffing because we've been acutely
aware as counselors how massively
overstretched so many officers have been
and how difficult it has been for them
to to respond to all the priorities that
they had let alone respond to our
questions or or you know information
that we wanted from them on that can you
just clarify for me for 4.37 about cap
no no it's not it's the one above 4.36
salary void Target why why have we got a
Target in respect of that because it
seems to me to cut against what we're
trying to do elsewhere or have I
misunderstood what that's about
um so salary void targets is that we
know throughout
um the year some posts will become
vacant and unfortunately
um it usually takes us a longer period
of time to recruit that post than it
does in terms of the notice period that
the officer has to serve so typically
say someone will say
thanks very much
um but I'm going somewhere else they may
have a one two or three month notice
period
that the manager will try to kick kick
start recruitment immediately however
you've got to advertise you've got to
interview and then you've got to select
that will take a length of time in
itself even then when you've told the
successful applicant they'll figure okay
great I'm now going to have my notice in
and so you say for the Post that's got a
one month notice period you're probably
looking at I don't know two-month void
two three month void yeah so you're
carrying we always know we're going to
carry some vacancy in our in our budgets
anyway so if we if we didn't put in in
that we'd be over budgeting for so
um we've seen that we've been hitting
our targets quite comfortably so we've
put some extra money on top of that just
because of a turnover and staff as much
as anything
so it's not that it'll it doesn't
restrict our establishment any further
in terms of what we're doing it's just
reflecting the reality of what we spend
because of those times that we've got
vacant posts
thank you my concern was that it might
be we're going to have a you know a
moratorium of three months so that I've
worked in an organization like that and
trying to pick up somebody else's work
three months later just you waste so
much time it's actually not a saving
um no I have as well and it tends you
tend to get situations uh like coming
mid-year when there are particular
budget issues that you can't address
through other management action and you
go this it's an it's the obvious one
right no recruitment on vacant posts
until we've got it's really it is
difficult for staff but it's not an easy
option it's not something we like to do
but it's one that when things are
difficult we need to balance the budget
in year that we do look to um to
consider in terms of service efficiency
I I can't see with the last thing I
would want it is and sometimes it can be
self-defeating because there are some
services that you've got to
um the staff so we wouldn't do that say
in Frontline services like waste
collection and Street cleansing
you could draft a bring agency staff in
and some other services you'd end up
making an exempt from anyway for sort of
homelessness for example you've we have
a statutory Duty we have to provide a
certain level
um so we'd look at a case-by-case basis
anyway but it's yeah it's it's not a
situation anyone ever wants to be in no
that's great thank you and and
congratulations on on those Staffing
aspects in particular but on the budget
generally I mean just um just to build
on that you may have seen
um I believe it's published yesterday
report that's going to general purposes
committee next Monday in terms of the
restructure of the corporate management
team the funding for that is is all
reflected in this this budget the the
actual implications are set out in a
report but
there's not a concern that this
approving that report on Monday Kai
bushes this budget it's all
self-contained it's it's yeah it's
manageable
just to correct Chris and I don't
normally have to do that but if my diary
it's actually on Tuesday so don't turn
up on Monday
my apologies
okay is there any more questions or
comments uh Council King
yeah just one thing I've just noticed
and that's um reading about the Margate
Town deal and it says about
um initiatives including creative Land
Trust etc etc doesn't mention anything
about the
um development at Walpole Bay now I know
it only says including I'm just checking
that that hasn't been shelved at all
not to my knowledge
um and I certainly don't want to set the
cat amongst the pigeons that the only
thing I will caveat with the Margate
Town deal is obviously
there's High inflation and construction
at the moment and as the schemes are
progressed there may be the need to
manage the programs in terms of scaling
some of them back it's not my
understanding that's been done at all so
I don't want to worry
um anyone that spent time I'm just
putting a sort of a health warning on
this one all those sort of capital
programs when we when we scaled them up
initially were based on a different
environment in terms of construction
costs and there's been no further
Government funding that's been provided
to meet that shortfall in terms of
inflation so officers are working really
really hard to scale the projects as
much as they can and meet the initial
brief but obviously if that is the if
that does come to pass there's various
levels of governance that arrange
associated with either the Margate Town
deal or the leveling up scheme so they
would go to through those appropriate
stages so there's the board terminal
board that would have to approve that
and it would come back to
um Council and cabinet to review and
approve the revised skin just not
something our officers will do in
isolation but we are on our risk
register with those schemes construction
and inflation cost is right at the top
it's the it's the highest risk
okay anyone else
oh Council Yates
it wasn't a just common as a
recommendation so I was going to come to
that so it's no more questions comments
we are asked if do we want to take any
recommendations back to cabinet so
there's a short time thank you Joe
um so at a recent um climate change
cabinet advisor group officers informed
members
um and and as I was a member of this
group uh this is what we heard that
there's an increased demand being placed
on home Energy Service
and this small team of two officers have
provided invaluable expert service
to our residents join these most
challenging of times so following this
I've worked closely with officers
um to present a proposal for members to
consider tonight for recommendation and
this is recommendation to cabinet for
inclusion in this year's budget or next
year's budget so I'm proposing that we
introduce a third officer to the home
Energy Service who will provide a cold
Buster service
and this will be for private rented
households and in practice what this
means is that we have an officer
available who can visit low-income homes
in the district and that officer will
then help to install low-cost measures
such as power power down devices on
plugs radiator foils behind radiators
LED bulbs carbon monoxide alarms draft
proofing chimney balloons making
adjustments to hot water and heating
temperatures and demonstrate smart
metering
um so officers have officers have
advised that the cost of providing the
service will be 35 000 pounds
uh per year and this can be fully funded
from our existing better care fund
allocation
um so therefore
um there will not be a need to find a
general fund budget saving to fund this
so the recommendation is for a third
officer to the home Energy service at a
cost of 35 000 funded from the better
better care
fund allocation
thank you thank you Council Yates uh
Charles has made a note of that for you
so yeah that's your vote forget your
Council coach a second that yeah
did somebody one of the officers want to
come back on it okay thank you I thought
it might be worth just adding a little
bit of context so the um the better care
fund is an annual allocation from
central government that we receive that
pays for a range of different things
under our housing assistance policy
which is a document that's published on
the council's council's website
um the primary function of the better
care fund is to pay for mandatory
disabled facilities grants and we spend
something like about three million
pounds a year on mandatory disabled
facilities grants that housing
assistance policy also sets out a number
of other schemes that we fund with that
money including the existing Energy
Efficiency officers but we also fund
Occupational Therapy Services to help
speed the process of applying for
disabled facilities Grant we fund a
handyman services and we fund a hospital
discharge service to help people who are
coming out of hospital but need some
adaptation adaptations in their home
before they are able to return home so
it's funding quite a wide range of
issues I think
Council Yates is right in saying that
there is potentially capacity within
that money to to add to that portfolio
of services and maybe do some more
Energy Efficiency but it needs to be in
a in the context of a review of the
whole of the better care fund
allocations so I think what I'd quite
like to suggest is that we we bring a
report that sets out where we are with
our better care fund allocations what we
expect
to have to spend on mandatory grants and
what else is available for for other
services of which this is a you know a
clearly a
an area that that you might want to
support but there may be other things
that you also want to support in that
kind of General broad range of services
that we provide with that money
so does that give you hope with Council
Yates
there we go that's an interesting one
um so
from our side we are making this
proposal because um
we believe the time is now
um we are in an incredibly tough uh
energy crisis at the moment
I've got residents who are telling me
they're paying 400 pounds a month on
electricity on on their energy and gas
um
and
now is the time to do this and I think
if we start it now then actually this
scheme could well expand as we prove the
service having TDC staff going into our
most vulnerable resident homes
um and installing measures that they can
see and they don't need they don't need
to own the their home to have these
measures put in
um
and yeah we have worked with officers on
the scheme so it is a scheme that has
been
um
uh kind of worked on with officers as
um the shadow uh the shadow group are
allowed to work with officers to develop
an alternative budget and this is our
alternative budget proposal which we
would like members of the ocean excuse
me panel to recommend tonight obviously
the recommendation tonight doesn't
finish this discussion it goes back to
cabinet and then to full Council so
um
I think some work potentially my counter
would be while some work can happen
between now and cabinet to have a look
at those further ideas but I would still
recommend that this is done because
considering the price of energy at the
moment there's never been a better time
to introduce this thank you
I can calculates
okay so at the end of that what do other
members of the panel think about that
recommendation
still
counseling
having listened to Bob Porter I'm a bit
concerned about could this have an
impact on an area of funding for for
people with disability uh also does your
funding actually include the cost of uh
the insulation the light bulbs is it
just the Staffing cost I totally support
the proposal but I think it would be
better to to receive some sort of report
from Bob Porter on the exact nature of
of the the money available and if that
all of the money isn't available the
possible impact on another group of
vulnerable residents people with
disabilities so I support it but I need
more information on the possible impact
on other areas of the funding
anyone else
you have good food
um just say the 35k is not just for the
labor so 20 28 000 pounds is the labor
and then seven thousand pounds is for
um the equipment
um so that has been taken into account
it wasn't my understanding that this
would have any impact on the existing
um
on the provision of different Services
because I think some officers time is
actually being reduced and there's a gap
there that can help fund this but um
from my understanding this wasn't going
to impact other services obviously I
take what the officers said tonight but
I still think
if we agree this doesn't mean this isn't
full Council this is just taking it to
the next step
and then we can again take a look at
this between now and the council but I
prefer to to push this forward now and
then have a further discussion a cabinet
Council if more information can be
provided which counters what I've heard
thank you
thank you councilor so is anybody
against taking that recommendation
forward
um the the benefit we have with this is
that
um given that it's externally funded it
doesn't necessarily need to be approved
as part of the budget setting cycle
appreciate that Council Yates has uh is
setting up the labor groups position
here in terms of a budget amendment
um
it can be taken forward as part of the
budget but also because the funding is
there but
um we don't necessarily need to go
through the same full Council approval
steps so it could be dealt with via OSP
and just cabinet to approve the
expenditure as opposed to council
needing to approve an overall increase
in the budget
sorry that probably complicates matters
rather than simplifies them
um but but ultimately what I'm saying is
it the decision doesn't need to be taken
right now by OSP if they do not wish to
there's still opportunities to do so but
equally Council Yates and other councils
still have the opportunity to make
amendments to the budget as part of the
budget setting process at full Council
in February as well yeah I think that
clarifies it so we've taken that
recommendation forward to cabinet and
Charles has got it all written down
yeah I asked if anybody did not agree
with it and nobody so is everybody in
support of that recommendation
yeah everyone's in support
was there any more recommendations does
anybody want to make
no okay so we move on to item number
seven on the agenda which is the HRA
budget so I have 2023 24 so I'll call on
a game because it's Mr blender oh yeah
thank you chair it's your night it is
indeed but I probably will lean on Mr
Porter um quite heavily for this one
because these uh him and his team have
done quite a lot of work on this
um so the the sort of the key decision I
think around the HRA is where rents are
going to sit that that's the the that's
the challenging issue a lot of the other
items in the budget reports for the HRA
there's not too much room for maneuver
there are lots of pressures on the
budgets in terms of
um energy costs I think the report sets
out it's 50 so 50 increase in energy
costs there's other inflation linked
pressures that we've got lots of our
contracts repairs and maintenance and
otherwise seeing CPI or RPI linked
increases uh the other pressure I'm sure
Mr Porter can talk to it at far more
detail on uh with greater knowledge of
the subject than I can awakened watch
pressures that we're seeing next year so
in terms of the the framework that we've
got for setting rents this year it's
it's it is different
um to previous years usually with rents
they're allowed to be increased by CPI
plus one percent that's the limit that
we're set but inflation uh obviously at
very high historic levels
um we've had a different
um set of parameters put in place the
government consulted on what the limits
should be this year their options were
three five or seven percent and they've
actually allowed us to increase rents up
to seven percent uh that's for both
social and affordable rents
we are presenting a seven percent
increase that's largely because the HRA
still is in deficit so if you look at
the bottom line for the HRA there's
still a significant deficit that we need
to recover we're assuming that we return
to the CPI Plus one percent next year
and that would be looking at rent
increases that possibly could be in
double digits those rental increases are
fundamental to getting the HRA back into
Surplus without doing that we end up in
a situation where we we end up below our
recommended minimum balances in a pretty
short order
that that probably is just stuff that
sounds like accounting sort of gumpty
but the fundamental thing in Practical
terms that will stop us from doing is
delivering the number of new homes that
we want to because the rental increases
under right housing delivery in terms of
building new homes we need those income
streams there the more income that we've
got allows us to build a greater number
of homes
um so that's that obviously is the the
tricky issue to square do you increase
rents in order to generate sufficient
income to get the HRA back into Surplus
and also the finance are what I would
say is really ambitious house building
program to get more affordable homes
into the district the other thing to
bear in mind in terms of the rental
increases is that
um a large majority of our tenants 75
percent are in receipt of some form of
either housing benefits or Universal
Credit that will go towards paying for
this increase so the the when the rents
increase the amount that they can
recover through the Universal Credit or
the housing benefit is increased as well
so we have a policy in place for our
affordable homes that they are all below
the local housing allowance rate which
sets the amount of housing benefit or
Universal cover credit that can be
recovered or 80 of the mark private
sector Market rents to give you an idea
of how we're trying to pitch rents and
ensure that they're still affordable
they'll all still be within the that
that policy framework even the
affordable
um properties
um if we were to apply a seven percent
increase across all of them there would
be 10 properties that would go above
that threshold so what we do is we cap
them so that those properties those 10
won't actually see the full seven
percent increase they'll see a
relatively lower increase that takes
them up to that threshold so that if
they are eligible for support with their
housing costs they're still able to
recover
um that through Universal Credit or
through housing benefit
um those were the the sort of main
points I wanted to sell out I think the
key thing for me is to stress the
importance of the rental increases to
ensure the financial sustainability and
robustness of the HRA we're still
catching up with the rental
reductions that we had to have in place
from 2016 to 2020 for four years in a
row we had to reduce rents by one
percent
um so that resulted in a cumulative
almost five percent reduction in rents
when at the same time inflation was
going up so our costs were going up
which put a lot of strain on the HRA and
really is the reason why we are in
deficit now that wasn't what our
business plan was that anticipating at
that moment in time but
um it's probably best to fire if I
stopped talking and hand over to Mr
Porter who hopefully won't the expert in
the room on these muffins well I think
Chris has been quite modest because I'm
not sure he's left me an awful lot to
say
um I mean Chris is absolutely right that
the um you know the big pressure this
year is From inflation and we all know
inflation is running very high and a lot
of the costs
um in in the HRA are inflation links so
all of the contracts including our main
responsive repairs contracts
um is is in inflation linked and where
we've got um communal services that
we're providing particularly communal
heating you know they're subject to a
very high fuel cost increases as well
and same as everybody else so so there
are real pressures for inflation within
the business plan
um this this time round
um the other the other I guess
significant
growth item in this agenda in Revenue
terms is and Chris did refer to it is
the waking watch provision so we've had
a waking watch provision
in the budget um for more than a year
now providing
24-hour on-site offices at each of our
five tower blocks with external wall
insulation
the reason that we have that in place is
a result of the fire risk assessments
for those buildings and we've been
working on a
the installation of new align alarm
systems and new Fire strategies with our
external fire risk assessors and with
the fire service
to move to a point where we don't need
to have a waking watch in place there's
only two routes for us to get to that
point one is sound of alarms in every
single flat
and and
um what they call a simultaneous
evacuation strategy so if the fire alarm
sounds it sounds and everybody's flat
and we uh affect an evacuation of the
building and we are installing those
alarms and we've pretty much completed
it but there are a handful of tenants in
each block that won't let us in to do
that work
um so we're having to go through
injunction procedures with the court to
get into those Flats to fit those alarms
the only other way to get to a point
where we can stand that down of course
is to remove and replace the external
wall insulation and you will have seen a
thinking that your last meeting
proposals
related to the refurbishment of tower
blocks including funding from government
for the ex removal and replacement of
external wall insulation and our bid to
the social housing decub fund for
upgrading the Energy Efficiency of those
blocks as well
um
so that money
um is in this capital budget to deliver
those programs
um I do want to stress the complexity of
those programs but we and we have
programmed it over
um 20 23 24 and 24 25.
um
and obviously once they those are if we
aren't able to get into every flat to
install alarms once we've completed
those programs we'll be able to stand
those waking watch services
I suppose there's a footnote to all of
that we have seen as well as helping to
maintain safety standards for residents
in those blocks we've seen some other
benefits from having 24-hour on-site
staff in terms of being able to you know
deal with fly tipping and rubbish in the
stairways dealing with antisocial
Behavior collecting evidence and just
generally creating a feeling of security
for residents in those buildings so you
know we've definitely seen some benefits
and of course last year we also
increased
our our own employees that are dedicated
to the tower blocks I mean it recruited
two additional housing response officers
dedicated to the tower blocks to deal
with some of those issues as well so all
of that is wrapped up in this in this
budget proposal and adds a bit of
pressure to the revenue account and
there's
um as Mr Blundell says you know getting
the balances the the getting the account
back into a surplus year on year is
really critical for the long-term
um viability of the housing stock and
the business plan
um I think the only other
um thing I really would want to
highlight is the capital program
um and um you know I'm
the fact that we've got the um uh the
amount the amount of Reserve we've got
in the business plan means that we are
able to deliver some really quite
ambitious Capital programs including all
the money for the tower blocks but also
substantial
allocations of capital funding for our
new build program and the schemes that
we've already delivered and the ones
that we're progressing at the moment
um through design stage with with
allocated funding will mean that over
since 2015 we will have delivered over
200 new homes that I think that is
really quite a fantastic achievement for
an authority of our size
um and and to be able to continue to put
over eight million pounds a year into
new build over the next seven eight nine
year period I think um is um something
we should be really proud of
um so I think they're they're the main
points I wanted to make but obviously if
there's any questions happy to Taylor
thank you uh well to members any
questions and comments you'd like to
make
councilor Huxley
thanks chair thanks Bob
um just to say in page 136 of your Annex
on the HRA Capital program
0.4.1 so 23 24 24 25 Capital programs
including an additional 150 000 pounds
budget to install wooden windows across
a number of sites
that's interesting
why why wouldn't are the double glaze to
do with zero net carbon policy of TDC
well I can answer that quite easily
they're in conservation areas yeah
that's what I thought so be enlisted
buildings that owned by TDC so it would
be happy we're not necessarily listed
some of them we do have some listed
buildings but generally it's because
they're in in conservation areas you
tell which sites or was it sort of oh
now you're testing me I don't I can get
I can get you a list it doesn't matter
if you want me to that's right thanks
anyone else guess the wing
I'd like to say thank you to the housing
team especially since we moved from East
Kent housing so you know I think I had
one and a half years as a counselor
under the East Kent housing regime and
then move into us taking it back in
house and as a World Council I've had
significantly lower uh concerns with
housing Harbor towers sits in my
ordinance I was going to ask you about
the the sort of associated benefits of
having the waking watch because I know
that a significant number of residents
in Harbor Towers really appreciate the
waking watch being being there and I I
think they'd be quite upset to see it go
because I think it does offer them uh
security and I suspect in the other two
towers where maybe there's a bit more
antisocial Behavior it's probably gone a
hell of a way to dealing with some of
that anti-social behaviors is that
something we can review to keep or find
additional funding to keep the waking
watch but I'd just like to say thank you
to the housing Team all of them that the
the homeless we seem to have less
homeless people on our streets the ones
that we do have seem to be the the
entrenched ones that are difficult to
reach so I do I do feel that we're
moving in the in the right in the right
direction in a in an area of council
work which is really difficult so thank
you
anyone else
looks like a note so we're asked if we
want to make any recommendations so I
presume there's
none to make excellent okie dokie making
it nice and easy for me uh all right
item eight on the agenda is the review
of the overview and security panel work
program for 2022-23
so do any members any comments to make
on the work program
Council Curry
thank you chair um yeah I'd just like to
update members regarding the TDC and
Parish in town
council's collaboration working party
um Following last year's meetings with
officers
the cabinet and Parish and town Clarks
uh Charles has put together a draft of
our recommendations and these will be
shortly sent to working party members
and the final report will be presented
to the panel in the first quarter of
this year
thank you yeah thanks Council Curry
anyone else
nope okay then uh we're asked to note
the report
noted
uh moving on to the last one on the
agenda the forward plan and exempt
cabinet report list unless there's
something from the plan that the panel
wish to discuss or consider then the
members are asked to notice the report
noted and that brings us to the end of
the meeting so I'd like to thank
officers and members of the cabinet and
members of the council for coming
Stephen thank you and thanks sir making
it easy for me thank you